my thesis or theory would be that
salesforce thinks they can run this
independently yet
use their sales force at salesforce and
their marketplace to make this the hub
of all of their products and to get
big enterprises who already have
salesforce to just add slack and have
slack be part of that whole
sort of operating system there right and
if they have all these young companies
those young companies can grow into the
whole suite of products
that salesforce has and remember you
have to think opportunistically
if the opportunity to buy slack was
there and slack
is flat maybe a bunch of the large
shareholders in slack
had lost faith and they were just like
you know what this thing's not going to
break out if it was going to break out
it would have broken out it's growing
slow it's got microsoft we need to make
a decision here so maybe the board was
just like you know what
this is a safer bet for us to cash in
our chips now and to move on
and make this part of a bigger
enterprise where they can funnel
more potential customers to it because
they obviously were having a hard time
getting past this microsoft teams
competitor so this is you know kind of
i don't want to say defeat but if it was
growing massively
and the board felt that this was like a
home run maybe this offer would
seem like you were leaving money on the
table just to get a 30 or 40 premium on
the current stock price
the board was probably like you know we
really want to go 10x here we want to go
20x here we want to become a 250
billion dollar company we'd rather get
there on our own get to 150 billion
whatever it is
like tesla has or peloton is doing or
uber is doing right now other companies
like can this be a strong independent
company and i guess they made the
decision
we don't think that this can be a strong
independent company now why this company
didn't merge with
zoom that would have been a juggernaut
because cessna's been around a long time
might have made more sense for zoom and
slack to collaborate but
i guess zoom maybe just didn't want to
make the offer and then you have to
wonder why would microsoft allow this to
happen
why wouldn't they get involved i guess
they feel like their product is good
enough or maybe they don't want to pay
the price for slack or they don't have
yet another brand
to manage if you look at it in context
you know facebook uh did something
similar when they bought whatsapp for
19 billion and that was a significant
portion of the value of facebook at the
time
and i think history will look at that as
a pretty good acquisition maybe they
overpaid a little bit
but thankfully nobody else got that
brand right so there's a blocking
strategy there it's a blocker so if
salesforce gets this
keeps him in the game oracle doesn't get
it microsoft doesn't get it
that's a blocking strategy which is why
microsoft probably should have made
a run out and i'm sure we will find out
that they did also in this sort of zone
linkedin got acquired by microsoft for
26 billion so this
is amongst the the biggest acquisitions
we've seen in tech i mean they're
obviously
telecom deals and and silicon deals that
have occurred as well that are very
large but outside of those giant telecom
deals
hp merger all that kind of stuff this is
this is up there in modern history as
one of the largest that we've seen in a
long time remember
uh youtube was 1.6 billion instagram was
one billion
beats by dre was three billion i mean
these things were very small by
comparison this is
essentially 20 if it wants i'm going out
at 20 billion or 24 billion
this would be the equivalent of 20
instagrams or 20
or 15 maybe youtube acquisitions now
those were in a different era but
here we are and it is super notable
salesforce is getting this because it
does seem like somebody else would have
made a run at it
and so you gotta wonder maybe they just
weren't willing to pay the price or they
just feel like
the company is stuck in the mud and
they're not going to
get out of it